does the sort of onset banter get
infected by the pure ility of the show
do you find yourselves being more
childlike onset Lee would be normally we
just finished filming the new series
that the out lights for this year and
one of the days we were in a forest and
we had sort of we went for a little walk
for lunch
and just ended that's quite so we walk
we're all in costume we're all supposed
to be working but we decided to push Joe
down like a whole a tree had been
uprooted and there was a little ditch
and we kind of dare Joe to get in and
then poked him with sticks and made him
get in this little hole and as soon as
you win we just ran from him once he was
in there just leg did and left him and
then he got in trouble for having a
dirty costumes yeah um which of you is
closest to your character in the show
hopefully not you James and probably not
like so that leaves me and Joe I think
it fight it out I think it's that thing
where you sort of take yourself and like
a bicycle parkings bigger I mean you're
a gamer well you know you get by think
about you think yeah like a wheel hop
yourself you know you you know don't you
would you say that it's been set so I'll
say it I'm a nerd there you go put the
speaker's you can't say that at latitude
where can you show right right no I hope
I'm not and Joe's intense and weird but
not quite as intense and weird
assignment
[Laughter]
I would say two things I think two
things first of all I mean if you're
gonna you have to act like embarrassment
it's probably gonna look a little bit
like what you look when you're
embarrassed because that's how you know
what embarrassment is and second of all
the writers as it's gone on I think of
written more towards what we're like as
people to avoid us having to is the
actor just the at singing so everything
right I get my costume on light yes
sometimes you just leave it cheaper so
much like the air you have to wear the
jacket you've just finished filming the
third series all right Lydia
yeah I'm Friday we finished what can you
tell us about it yes so West is more the
same really but the last viewer in the
upper-60s girlfriend yeah quite a few
episodes as well oh [ __ ] so that's quite
a big storyline
to a pop the thing is when you describe
in between us it does just sound genuine
it's nothing half of the point is like
when you're that about the time it seems
I think the most important thing in the
world but the point of the show is to
say it's me
it really is you just thanks to the
biggest pop in point insulative really
when you're that age obviously the
smallest thing like your world is so
small so the smallest thing like going
to a pub is amazing you know but it's
not really as it yeah it's just one of
the one of the episodes in this will
stays at home alone
what's the the so tangible change going
from lower sixth to upper six of being I
genuinely remember thinking that when I
was like when I moved into like the
upper 606 the remember thinking right
who's that you girls in rags come on we
can do this we're all done that's the
power and no chose character in one of
the episodes wears a hat yes is why I'm
sort of trying to change himself in my
hair yeah really think yeah like showed
up the festival witness do you think
there's a potential for the for the
students to follow the the boys when
they go off to university or going to
work whatever they do after Scott I
don't I mean it'd be quite contrived to
have them all go to the same yeah uni
cuz obviously are turn think Neil and
will will end up going to the same
University
but I think possibility yeah I don't
think I'll be a fool I think it's just I
think it's not trying to be like oh we
only do a certain amount of series and
we'll quit
whilst we're ahead because we'd milk it
forever
but I think it's just because the
writers you know maybe if they get a
good idea or something we might I mean
we were scraping the barrel for ideas
already what happened yeah Joe gets a
hat and when I go see if by the night at
the first series it was the writers I
could say it's maybe doing like a
Christmas special or something like that
or if there's a good idea in and if
every funny thing I'm sure we'd all love
to do it pretty much all of the first
series is autobiographical for most of
the embarrassing stuff happened to
either one of the two writers mainly Ian
- so for example were skidding like what
you did when you're asked like to be a
woman offered him sex and rather than
saying yes I'll do that he took his
shoes off and skidded in like a halt and
was like let's skid let's have fun on
this ski get to know each other
how old was in when this was after was
he oh he was actually in uni when they
were in their early twenties it was
stuff happened when they were at school
but then when he first tragic characters
I mean Ian broke his wrist last week
when he was pole dancing in Maria he's
gonna really enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]